[Music]
that's a fat nut
yeah literally yeah busting it out of
the sack all right what do you want to
watch
okay i got two videos for you yeah to
start it off
let's go one of them is a video of jeff
that i just sent it was a little
interview
he did when he just got back down to
earth okay from our
from our uh ship so here played that one
i sent it to
my nose is leaking from the cocaine
that's why i'm having a panic attack can
can i get a can i get a
paper towel or something while we watch
this space ambitions than going
to the edge of it did this moment
motivates you to push
deeper into the cosmos hell yes
[Laughter]
damn his laugh is evil now ambitions
than going to the edge
hell yes
his life was crazy before but
now it's like evil bro that's what trend
does to your laugh
yeah it makes you laugh crazy
he laughs like steve carell yeah let's
hit it one more time
this moment motivates you to push deeper
into the cosmos
hell yes
hell yes
yeah anyways does this everyone's quiet
everyone's tempered does this motivate
you to push deeper into the cosmos
hell yes
see you're not cut out to be a
billionaire you can't even laugh hard
that's true that's true
okay second video now that i sent wait
this you're gonna [ __ ] love this and
turn it up a little bit too
this one's really about the sound okay
what do you think is the sound cloud for
billionaires by the way because you know
like soundcloud is like before you
become like
considered like a real artist yeah what
do you think the soundcloud for
billionaires is oh
uh like what type of company do you
think they start
[Laughter]
[ __ ] whatever i just said so i was just
thinking about like
billionaires sitting in a circle and
then like they're clowning one
billionaire because like he doesn't have
a good laugh
yeah was jack ma have you heard his
laugh
sucks dude it's not good it's really
small
actually no if you're an evil
billionaire small laugh works as well
yeah that does actually that's scary as
[ __ ]
yeah you can't have like uh we can come
back
i've seen what's a bitch-ass billionaire
laugh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that's kind of that's weak that's very
weak
yeah is that good or bad scary or not i
think
what about this one
kind of sounds like a grandpa got kicked
in the balls what about
[Laughter]
that one's real pretty okay scary it's
pretty
you got a pretty laugh
yeah meet canyon dude the cody watch the
first
10 seconds of i think my voice is in
that one
actually yeah yeah he like sent me a dm
and was like hey if you want to like do
one of these characters that's in the
background you can and i was like [ __ ]
yeah so i sent him the lines but then
i was listening for my voice i couldn't
hear it but if you if you listen to the
first
it's probably the funniest like first 10
seconds of any
any of the sketches i've ever seen
stinks stinks all right so this is
called the most
demented synth demo i've ever seen it's
someone like demoing their vst
deranged deranged all right okay
we even did a hip-hop track with theresa
this song here starts with patty in the
intro
then a very special rapper and then
theresa in the chorus
check it out
while i listen to the girls
was that corpse husband
you'll play that against that corpse
husband pop track with theresa
knickknacks patty in the intro then a
very special rapper
and then theresa in the chorus check it
out
yeah yeah hey hey
[Music]
the bass
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's corpse's wife
with teresa and the chorus
who is the swiss tourist [ __ ]
why is she part of the synth who gives a
[ __ ] you don't need her picture when
you're [ __ ] making
[Music]
in the studio like yo you got that uh
white
singing lady simulator uh yeah i got
that white singing lady vst hold on who
do you want
pull up teresa uh teresa pull up theresa
nah
you know who i like who what
patty patty you got any patricia in
there
what about beatrice yeah i got some
beatrice hold on just go to the replies
to this tweet
scroll down yeah step back hit me with
the knick-knack paddy whack
this is both a reference to a children's
nursery rhyme and patty singing in the
intro
oh no oh no hit me with the boom while i
listen to the late
to the girls thing that's the second
part
i wonder how they annotate that part hit
me with the boom while i listen to the
girls saying
that's pretty fire next level [ __ ]
every time you say that line i just i
feel like i have to sing along what's
that one
down below that one the wonder woman
soundtrack
now let's add more reverb and turn on a
little delay
and maybe add a little background music
[Music]
that's pretty fire actually that's crazy
let's is that shakira
no don't disrespect patty like that
patty's got pipes yeah
this is a new michael bay trailer
[Music]
[Laughter]
sigourney weaver
and matt leblanc as the arabian knights
matt leblanc and sigourney weaver are
two arab merchants that go on a quest
for their culture
[Laughter]
no one in this movie is egyptian or arab
[Music]
featuring halsey singing arabian
inspired music
featuring halsey topless
tilda swinton is cleopatra
damn
you